[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen schön dass Sie dabei sind wie
auch Norbert Lehmann für den Sport
[Musik]
Entlastungen für die Verbraucher der
Bundestag beschließt die Gas- und
strompreisbremse
zu wenig Medikamente kein Klinikpersonal
Eltern und Kinderärzte klagen über total
überlastetes Gesundheitssystem
und Boris Becker ist wieder ein freier
Mann Großbritannien schiebt die
Tennislegende nach Deutschland ab
sie wird Millionen von Bürgern und auch
Unternehmen zu Gute kommen die gar die
Preisbremse für Gas und Strom die der
Bundestag heute beschlossen hat nachdem
noch bis zuletzt daran gefeilt worden
war diese Preisbremse soll im kommenden
Jahr greifen und bei den rasant
gestiegenen Energiekosten entlasten zur
Finanzierung werden auch hohe Gewinne
der Energieproduzenten abgeschöpft aus
berlin-
sie sollen uns über den kalten Winter
bringen Gas und Stromkraftwerke damit
die Energie aber bezahlbar bleibt für
Haushalte Gewerbe und Industrie wird der
Staat mit milliardenschweren
Entlastungen helfen
gerade in einer Krise muss gelten wer
ein Beitrag leisten kann der übernimmt
Verantwortung wer Unterstützung braucht
der bekommt sie und so machen wir aus
dem viel herbei beschworenen Winter der
Wut ein Winter des Solidarität bei
privaten Haushalten und kleinen
Unternehmen wird der Preis von 80% des
vorjahresverbrauchs gedeckelt Strom
kostet maximal 40 Gas maximal 12 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde der Staat zahlt die
Differenz zum Marktpreis ab März 2023
dann auch rückwirkend für Januar und
Februar für die restlichen 20% des
Verbrauch soll der normale Marktpreis
gelten damit soll ein Anreiz gesetzt
werden Energie zu sparen Besitzer von Öl
und Pelletheizungen müssen Hilfe
beantragen kritik kommt von der
Opposition
dass sie entlasten wollen ist richtig
und ja das haben wir immer gefordert
aber sie machen es bürokratisch
halbherzig spät und hektisch bereits in
sechs Monaten soll es einen Bericht zur
Wirksamkeit der Preisbremse geben
weitere Änderungen sind also möglich
200 Milliarden Euro plant der Bund für
diesen und nächsten Winter ein viel Geld
dafür dass die Energie bezahlbar bleibt
es sind vor allem die Energiepreise die
die Inflationen die Höhe treiben im
Kampf gegen die Teuerung setzt die
Europäische Zentralbank aufsteigende
Zinsen nach jahrelangen Nullzinspolitik
gab es in diesem Jahr schon drei
Anhebungen auf zuletzt zwei Prozent
heute nun verkündete die EZB einen
weiteren etwas geringeren Zinsschritt
auf 2,5% über die Folgen Stefan
Schlösser
lange haben die Verantwortlichen der
Europäischen Zentralbank die Inflation
unterschätzt umso schneller handeln Sie
jetzt unter vierte zündschritt binnen
weniger Monate wird nicht der letzte
sein
wir gehen davon aus dass die Zinssätze
noch immer deutlich und stetig steigen
müssen um ein Niveau zu erreichen dass
ausreichend restriktiv ist um eine
rechtzeitige Rückkehr der Inflation zu
unserem mittelfristigen Ziel von 2% zu
gewährleisten
leichte Entspannung zwar an der
Tankstelle Autofahrer zahlen weniger für
einen vollen Tank als noch vor ein paar
Wochen insgesamt aber steigen die Preise
weiter insbesondere für Strom heizen und
Lebensmittel
es gibt aktuell noch keinen Grund zur
Entwarnung bei der Inflation die
Inflationsrate könnte eher noch mal
steigen und wird erst im ersten Quartal
deutlich nach unten wieder gehen grund
dafür sind die gaspreisbremse in
Deutschland und auch das 49 Euro Ticket
billiger wird es dann auch bei
niedrigeren Inflationsraten nicht die
Preise steigen nur nicht mehr ganz so
schnell für alle die einen Kredit
aufnehmen wollen wird es teurer jeder
der Geld braucht der muss damit rechnen
muss noch mehr Zinsen
Girokonto und Baugeld also bitte bereit
sind Erhöhung bedeutet auch mehr Geld
als er bezahlen muss gerade
Immobilienkäufer müssen tiefer in die
Tasche greifen die Bauzinsen haben sich
innerhalb eines Jahres vervielfacht
positiv dagegen es gibt wieder Zinsen
aufs Ersparte nicht viel aber immer noch
besser als Strafzinsen
es gibt neue Vorwürfe gegen die
abgesetzte Vizepräsidentin des
EU-Parlaments Eva Kaili es gehe um
mutmaßlichen betrug im Zusammenhang mit
der Bezahlung von parlamentsmitarbeitern
so die eu-staatsanwaltschaft sie
beantragte die Immunität von KI
aufzuheben gegen die Griechen wird auch
wegen Korruptionsverdacht ermittelt sie
soll sich gegen Geld für die Interessen
anderer Staaten eingesetzt haben nach
Presseberichten für Katha und Marokko
bleiben wir bei der EU letzter Gipfel
dieses außergewöhnlichen Jahres dabei
stand wieder die Ukraine ganz oben auf
der Agenda es ging um weitere Hilfen für
das Land in Höhe von 18 Milliarden Euro
doch Polen stämmte sich dagegen und
sprach von Erpressung fragen wir Ulf
Fröhler in Brüssel was war da los
als ich glaube dass eigentlich in diesem
Moment ein ziemlich viel Bewegung auf
den Gipfel entsteht und das ist erster
Erfolgsmeldungen gibt der Delegationen
sagen dass Polen den Widerstand
aufgegeben hat und damit doch jetzt
ziemlich sicher ist dass die Ukraine
Hilfe von 18 Milliarden Euro fließen
wird und auch beim Gaspreis Deckel
scheint Bewegung zu kommen die
Regierungschefs werden noch keinen
Deckel drauf macht auf das Thema jetzt
hier sondern am Montag das ist ziemlich
fest verabredet und dieser
gaspreisdeckel soll dann liegen zwischen
150 und 220 Euro das ist noch nicht klar
definiert aber und das war Deutschland
sehr wichtig es soll ein atmen der
Deckel sein das heißt wenn der
gaspreisdeckel bei 150 oder 200 € liegt
aber der Weltmarkt doch über diesen
Preis liegt dann kann dieser Deckel auch
wieder außer Kraft gesetzt werden damit
man eben Gas bekommt man sieht das ist
ein typischer europäischer Kompromiss wo
alle Gesicht waren können
viele Informationen danke für die
Einschätzung ultra nach Brüssel
in die Ukraine dort leiden die Menschen
laut UNO extrem unter den russischen
Angriffen auf zivile Ziele mehr als 10
Millionen Menschen haben keinen Strom
berichtet der Hochkommissar für
Menschenrechte Volker Turk nach seiner
ukraine-reise in vielen Wohnungen gibt
es weder Heizung noch fließend Wasser in
herson immer wieder unter Beschuss starb
erst gestern an achtjähriger Junge
vor diesem Krieg vor Kälte und Not sind
nach UN-Angaben inzwischen knapp acht
Millionen Menschen geflohen mehr als
eine Million davon nach Deutschland und
die meisten fühlen sich hier gut
aufgenommen so das Ergebnis einer
großangelegten Studie etwa jeder dritte
geflüchtete kann sich vorstellen
langfristig zu bleiben aber es wird
immer schwieriger die Menschen zu
versorgen und unterzubringen aus Hamburg
berichtet Sven Regen
zweimal in der Woche öffnet diese
private hilfsbörse für Menschen aus der
Ukraine von Kleidung bis Haushaltswaren
findet sich hier alles fürs tägliche
Leben viele Fragen auch nach bestimmten
Dingen wenn Sie etwas suchen freuen sich
wenn wir es haben und ich glaube die die
meisten freuen sich einfach dass das ist
ihnen das ganze ein bisschen leichter
macht 3000 Flüchtlinge kommen jeden
Monat in Hamburg an mehr als die Hälfte
davon aus der Ukraine die die schon
länger in der Hansestadt sind haben sich
mit der Situation arrangiert und
Zukunftspläne
Krankenschwester werden ich möchte
lernen wie das geht
Deutsch ich möchte Deutsch lernen und
dann einen normalen Job haben und meine
Frau und meine Tochter ernähren meine
Frau ist krank
die Kapazitäten der Hansestadt sind
nahezu erschöpft Container Dörfer wie
dieses beherbergen inzwischen mehr als
1300 Menschen auch die zählte eigentlich
nur Notunterkünfte müssen mit Unterhalt
halten
die Möglichkeiten der Menschen selber
was zu Unterbringung beizutragen sind
endlich sie haben selber zum Teil
Zukunftsängste und das merken wir
deutlich als statt da müssen wir
einspringen Hamburg muss also auch die
unterbringen die privat nicht mehr
wohnen können die Stadt mietet verstärkt
Hotels an und es wird weitere
containerdörfer geben
um von russischer energieunabhängig zu
werden setzt die Bundesregierung vor
allem auf Gaslieferungen per Schiff
damit das technisch funktioniert braucht
es schwimmende Terminals Deutschlands
erstes ist heute in Wilhelmshaven
angekommen die höchstperanza kann
verdichtetes Flüssiggas wieder in
normales Gas umwandeln und dann ins
Versorgungsnetz einspeisen eine erste
Ladung hat sie auch an Bord genug um
mindestens 50.000 Haushalte ein Jahr
lang zu versorgen
der Rüstungskonzern Rheinmetall will
mehr Munition in Deutschland produzieren
um die Bundeswehr und auch die Ukraine
zu versorgen vorausgegangen war ein
Streit mit der Schweiz die weigert sich
aus neutralitätsgründen dort produzierte
Munition für den Gepard Panzer an die
Ukraine zu liefern ab Juni soll die
Munition deshalb in Deutschland
gefertigt werden
es ist bereits beschlossen die
Bundeswehr will sich bis Mai 2024 von
ihrem gefährlichen Einsatz im
westafrikanischen Mali zurückziehen nur
wie und unter welchen Bedingungen bei
einem Treffen mit der Militärregierung
des Landes forderte
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht der
Schutz der Bevölkerung durch die
Bundeswehr dürfen nicht behindert werden
die deutschen Soldaten nehmen in Mali an
einer UN-Friedensmission Teil die aber
wird immer schwieriger seit die Militärs
die Macht im Land übernommen haben
hierzulande verzweifeln viele Eltern
gerade weil sie keine angemessene
Behandlung für ihre kranken Kinder
bekommen zum einen fehlen Medikamente
wie Husten oder Fiebersaft zum anderen
sind viele Kliniken überlastet weil
immer mehr Kinder mit
Atemwegserkrankungen kommen und weil
zeitgleich Ärzte und Pfleger krank sind
Krankenhäuser gehen in den Notbetrieb
Operationen werden verschoben Heikes
lanski und Sibylle Basler berichten
Lieferengpässe bei Kleinkind
Medikamenten und nicht nur da etwa 200
Präparate Fehlen der Grund aus
Kostengründen wurde bereits vor Jahren
die Produktion in Billiglohn Länder
verlagert zum einen ist wirklich seit
langer Zeit des Gesundheitssystem
definitiv kaputt gespart worden durch
die ganzen Rabattverträge die Firmen
haben reagiert haben ihre ganzen
Produktionen ins Ausland verlegt seit
Wochen platzen Kinderarztpraxen aus
allen Nähten Husten Schnupfen Fieber und
jeder Arzt weiß die notwendigen
Medikamente sind Mangelware im
schlimmsten Fall kann es tatsächlich
lebensbedrohliche Ausmaße annehmen das
ist eben schon erbärmlich und Antrag der
Linken Notstand in den Kinderkliniken
heute Thema im Bundestag das
profitsystem hat im Gesundheitsbereich
nichts verloren am deutlichsten wird
dies bei der Versorgung von Kindern sie
bauen auf kurzfristige Lösungen auf dem
Rücken der Beschäftigten aber die wissen
schon dass von ihnen keine Entschädigung
keine Wertschätzung zu erwarten ist der
Gesundheitsminister verspricht Abhilfe
er habe bereits die Personal
Untergrenzen aufgehoben die Budgetierung
ausgesetzt zusätzliche honorarkkräfte
ermöglicht dazu kommt nun wir werden
alle Eingriffe zur Not verschieben bei
Erwachsenen um den Kindern alles
anzubieten was wir anbieten können wir
lassen hier kein Kind zurück Hilfe Ruf
aus den Kinderstationen das Personal
geht auf dem Zahnfleisch Medikamente
fehlen Lösungen nicht schnell genug in
Sicht
und wir schauen noch mal in den
Bundestag dort wurde heute morgen
nämlich eine
Ära gewürdigt seit 50 Jahren ist
Wolfgang Schäuble ununterbrochen
Mitglied des Parlaments das ist Rekord
1972 war der CDU-Politiker erstmals
Abgeordnete später innen und
Finanzminister er meldete die deutsche
Einheit
überstand ein Attentat war verstrickt in
die CDU schwarz-geldaffäre zuletzt war
er Bundestagspräsident als einfacher
Abgeordneter will sich der 80-Jährige
weiter für effizientere und
bürgerfreundlichere Politik stark machen
Boris Becker ist wieder frei der frühere
Tennisstar hat nach Angaben seines
Anwalts das Gefängnis in Großbritannien
verlassen und ist nach Deutschland
ausgereist eigentlich war Bäcker im
April wegen
Insolvenzverschleppung zu zweieinhalb
Jahren Haft verurteilt worden doch die
britischen Gefängnisse sind so überfüllt
dass Ausländer vorzeitig entlassen
werden Andreas Stamm
sein letzter Gang in Freiheit Ende April
der Tag von Boris Beckers Verurteilung
die deutlich verkürzte Haftzeit ist kein
Promibonus ausländische Strafgefangene
können in Großbritannien früher
abgeschoben werden spart Steuergeld und
macht Platz in überfüllten Gefängnissen
akzeptiert um früher frei zu bekommen
normalerweise bedeutet eine Ausweisung
dass Bäcker in diesem Land 10 Jahre
nicht mehr erwünscht ist nicht einreisen
kann ab Herbst 24 dem Ende der regulären
Haftstrafe könnte Bäcker das Verbot
anfechten für einen der Wimbledon sein
Wohnzimmer nennt ein harter Schlag dort
zehn Jahre wohnte wie seine aktuelle
Freundin Lilian noch Ehefrau Lili und
sein jüngster Sohn Amadeus auch das
Insolvenzverfahren endet nicht künftige
Einnahmen auch in Deutschland gehen zum
Großteil an den britischen
Insolvenzverwalter in einem nun
veröffentlichten Interview Ausschnitt
kurz vor seiner Verurteilung zeigt sich
Bäcker am Boden
ich bin am Tiefpunkt
ich weiß nicht wie mir geschieht ich
werde mich dem Stellen mich nicht
verstecken oder wegrennen
in Deutschland könnte Becker heißt es
erstmal bei Mutter Elvira im heimischen
Leimen Unterschlupf finden und Zeit um
dort die größte Niederlage seines Lebens
aufzuarbeiten
Frankreichs Präsident macron Norbert
nach Argentinien steht Frankreich im
Finale der Fußballwelt gestern Abend
gegen Marokko kein berauschender sie
gegen die Überraschungsmannschaft dieses
Turniers aus Nordafrika der
Titelverteidiger auch in diesem Spiel
weniger mitreißend als viel mehr
kaltschnäuzig effektiv ja und einfach
erfolgreich
die Mannschaft feiert mit Präsident
macron in der Kabine die französischen
Fans in Paris auf den Chance Elysee ein
Jubel mehr in blau weiß und rot
der Pokal ist praktisch schon da der
Sonntag das ist nur noch reine Formsache
Frankreich gegen Marokko mit frühen Tor
und viel Akrobatik Theo ernannt ist das
Spiel lange Zeit offenes Slalom Lauf und
Randal kolumani bringen die Entscheidung
die hat jede Chance Weltmeister als
Spieler kann mit der ägyptricolor zum
zweiten Mal Weltmeister als Trainer
werden
unintelligible wir streben am Sonntag
den Titel an wie wunderbar
aber auch das gehört zur halbfinal-nacht
in Brüssel und Paris kommt es zu
Ausschreitungen und Festnahmen im
Montpellier stirbt bei einem Autokorso
ein 14-jähriger Junge
erste deutsche Medaille bei der Kurzbahn
schwimmen WM in Melbourne Anna Elend
holte über die 100 m Brust Bronze und
schwamm einen neuen deutschen Rekord zum
Wintersport da hat Biathlet Benedikt
doll erstmals in dieser Saison den
Sprung ist geschafft beim letzten
Sprintwettbewerb des Jahres in Le grande
alle zehn Scheiben abgeräumt ein
fehlerfreies schießen und dazu eine
beachtliche Laufleistung so schafft
Benedikt doll den Sprung aufs Podest das
fünfte Podium für Deutschlands
Männerteam in diesem Winter
vom Rennen habe ich mich heute irgendwie
total entspannt gefühlt und habe
versucht auch diese Lockerheit dann mit
ins Rennen zu nehmen knapp 40 Sekunden
fehlen doll auf den derzeit in einer
eigenen Liga agierenden Johannes Tinius
aus Norwegen der seinen fünften
Weltcup-Sieg nacheinander einfährt
und beim Abfahrtsrennen in Gröden
gelangen Joseph Ferstl ein
Achtungserfolg als Sechster feierte er
sein bestes Saisonergebnis und die
Qualifikation für die WM im Februar
knappe 13 Sekunden schneller als Sieger
Vincent kriechmayr aus Österreich Thomas
Dresden verpasste nach Fahrfehler die
Punkte Gänge und kam mit Schmerzen im
Oberschenkel ins Ziel
ja und fraglich ob er am Samstag bei der
Abfahrt an den Start gehen kann schauen
wir mal Danke Schön noch was Vorsicht
beim Rausgehen heute Nacht denn auch in
der kommenden Nacht wird es wieder glatt
durch Eisregen die Details hat gleich
Katja horneffer um viertel nach zehn
begrüßt Sie Christian Sievers im heute
journal wir wünschen Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend und alles Gute bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend tief ermute bringt erneut
Glatteis Regen und Schnee besonders hier
im Süden Deutschlands morgen übernimmt
hoch Casper und bringt vielen von uns
Sonnenschein der Glatteis Regen setzt in
diesen Stunden hier im südlichen
Baden-Württemberg ein und zieht im Laufe
der Nacht über München weiter nach
Passau morgen verlässt uns der Glatteis
Regen dann ostwärts aus dem
Glatteisregen wird im Laufe der Nacht
immer mehr Schnee und in diesem Bereich
können bis morgen früh durchaus zwei bis
zehn Zentimeter schneefallen und einige
Zentimeter Neuschnee gibt's auch in
Norddeutschland besonders türkisch wird
es wenn der Schnee auf den von Glatteis
überzogenem Boden fällt dann wird es
nämlich türkisch glatt und Sie sehen es
nicht in der Mitte Deutschlands ist es
meist klar und deswegen wird dort auch
am kältesten mit -6 bis - 14 Grad morgen
liegen die Höchsttemperaturen meist im
leichten Dauerfrost und morgen schneit
es noch weiter hier in Ober in
Niederbayern einige Schneeschauer gibt
es in Norddeutschland sonst wird das ein
freundlicher Freitag häufig mit
Sonnenschein das vierte
Adventswochenende bringt uns
Sonnenschein Nebel und Hochnebel in der
Nacht zum Montag droht dann aber wieder
Glatteisregen diesmal von Westen guten
Abend